you know the jungle it's a part of you
but exploring is not a game and you
don't look before you leap we're onto
something big Dora an ancient city made
of gold but amantha and your mother and
I are gonna prove it Emmie
I'm sorry sweetie you're not going look
being in the city around kids your own
age like Diego might help so you're
gonna get invited some of these party
called ramps the music sounds like this
got it
be careful that's what we want to say
cousin table you're so skinny and tough
you are way more energetic than I
remember
enjoy this isn't the jungle it's high
school it's life or death
keep a low profile
[Music]
and just be cool door okay what is this
where did you transfer from the jungle
here's the scavenger hunt list team out
in groups of four hola Dora
you'll help us find your parents and the
lost city of gold where are we all I see
is jungle see three mercenary armed
oh look Dora brought a knife on the
field trip everybody boom with me if you
want to leave I will with your parents
you're all in danger we're gonna die out
here
there's no need to overreact
[Music]
of course she knows this monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to keep going no matter what
she's freaking awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you